après le succès de votre roman viol
ordinaire vous revenez avec la suite
mais un homme tout simplement votre
souhait c'était d'aider les hommes
exactement ça va et pourquoi parce que
je voulais m'adresser aux hommes les
hommes ne vont pas chez les lip si les
hommes ne vont pas s'ils font une
dépression peut-être mais pas pour des
problèmes de couple les hommes ne vont
pas chez les psy il si c'est un homme
ils vont dire qu'ils vont me juger ils
vont trouver faible ils vont pas avec
une femme il ya toujours de la séduction
qui rentrent d'avoir une femme juive je
vaux je veux la séduire gens savent pas
où sont ces faiblesses je la vois alors
que les groupes d'hommes c'est
extraordinaire
alors ce livre c'est fait pour les
hommes silice pas tant pis pour eux
un homme tout simplement a demandé six
mois de recherches pour un monde oui ce
soir ce sera oui parce que je m'attaque
à des sujets que des fois que je connais
pas comme la justice réparatrice je
connaissais pas ça on va pas se vanter
d'un talent est la justice réparatrice
j'avais oui j'étais à lille en médiation
pour un litige de maison et puis j'avais
trouvé que la médiation c'était quelque
chose d'extraordinaire
puis bon je me suis renseigné et je
quelqu'un qui est une qui va se
renseigner et qui appelle les gens sauf
que le magazine pour être capable de
faire 1 promesse si demont clochard est
ce que ça vous choque
non sa petite oie je recherche un patois
avec vos émissions de télé comme par les
pourparlers avec un grand a vous avez
vraiment misé sur la communication pour
rapprocher les gens c'est la solution
c'est la solution se parler or nous
sommes en général poteau ne parle pas
même ceux qui parlent ne pas se parler
du rock et puis tu veux parler tu peux
parler de la chine et puis des dd ce qui
se passe entre entre pays mais tu peux
ne pas être capable de parler d'amour
chez avec puciers mans
ce que j'ai beaucoup aimée de votre
dernier livre c'est qu'il est écrit de
façon assez simple justement pour
rejoindre le plus de gens possible
d'avoir souhait c'est que monsieur
lentement flamand plus comprendre et
agir et changer peut-être ces
comportements je ne maîtrise pas je ne
me suis jamais adressé à une élite parce
que ils ont les moyens et physique les
financiers de se renseigner
je prends tous les autres tous les
autres puis on est nombreux à être dans
les autres je me poserai pas dans les
lieux c'est sûr que toute ma vie j'ai un
peu souffert de
ne pas être mis psychologue ni j'aurais
voulu avoir un gros titre j'étais
journaliste
bon je les fais ma façon ma façon faire
ça c'est faire du journalisme aussi se
renseigner pendant six mois c'est faire
du journalisme et avoir le talent d'en
faire une histoire
en dix ans un homme tout simplement je
peut se poser la question comment à 96
ans janette bertrand réussi à trouver
l'énergie la force d'écrire encore comme
ça quand je suis parti de l'école j'ai
les rues y met en 7e année la plupart
des petites filles de ma classe aller
travailler
à 12 ans 13 ans alors moi j'ai demandé à
mon père
d'affaires des études comme mes frères
et as tu essayé de me décourager en
france on va faire et puis il m'a dit
pouf et ouvre pas construire pourquoi
pour la bd couche c'est est ce que les
partisans j'ai dit oui je l'avais les
couches mais selon lui des affaires
alors je l'avais des couches aussi et
tout en apprenant des choses j'ai moi
j'apprends j'apprends j'apprends et je
remets aux autres c'est ça ma vie c'est
très simple
depuis que je suis entré chez vous je
vois des piles de papier comme ça et des
manuscrits partout c'est vraiment votre
projet écrire sa ville a demandé où
j'allais décrire leur vie je leur ai
fait confiance de 3 à combiers lors des
1000 2000 2000 j'en ai lu jeudi soir
lire 2 3 j'ai passé un été à lire du
matin au soir c'est tellement
passionnant c'est notre histoire
c'est notre histoire quoi en faire un
livre
oui oui le prochain livre est déjà
commencé et je suis pas seul je suis
avec laurent turcot
historiens qui est un rite
extraordinaire et on va écrire
l'histoire de ma naissance à aujourd'hui
1925 janette bertrand merci pour ce
magnifique entretien
[Musique]